all right why don't we speak next
to um let's speak to let's go
international let's speak to
carl from stockholm
carl from stockholm are you on are you
unmuted can you hear me
hmm all right that's too bad i was
hoping to
speak to carl let's go to schizo
from north carolina you're on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can awesome
uh pleasure to speak to you i found your
show not too
long ago um i have a couple questions
okay i have been dealing with
sorry i'm kind of a little nervous but
i've been dealing with
uh my fiance who is
buying into all of these conspiracies
that are going around
and basically she has
put an ultimatum in the relationship
she's basically said that if i get
vaccinated
it would be the end of our relationship
and
it's it's really stressing me out
because i'm constantly
like researching and finding that the
the claims of conspiracy theorists don't
hold water that's right when you
actually do the research that's correct
yeah so i but
the problem is i've seen her go from
being completely afraid of this when it
first started
and then attaching to these conspiracies
as a way to cope with the fear yep that
she was having
that's very because i was people would
rather take solace in the the conspiracy
which suggests that we have much more
control over things than we actually
have it's scary that this might be an
out of control pandemic
so folks would rather believe whatever
conspiracy theory about
the virus or the vaccine that's very
common yeah
the the the problem i'm finding myself
in is
because i i i haven't gotten vaccinated
yet and i i really do want to
because i have basically i have a
one-year-old child
and i'm not willing to take the risk
that i won't be here for him and uh that
makes a lot of sense
but for her it's not that for her it's
it seems that if i do so it's almost
like a religious belief where
it offends her that it will be the end
of our relationship
and basically it's boiled down to if i
do this i am
uh a stupid person for falling into this
this whole thing so i do you have any
recommendations like
well let's try i can't tell so let me
ask you a couple questions is this is
this
the the mother of the one-year-old you
just mentioned
yes it is okay um and uh
how long have you been together uh about
three
three years now and do you do you want
to continue together
yes absolutely i'm well i'm willing to
to to stick around because i
i also am afraid of the issues that will
happen
if i'm no longer in the relationship and
what she'll do in order to keep me away
from my son
that's a scary thing that's a scary let
me listen i'm gonna i'm gonna i don't
know the full situation and ultimately
you have to decide but let me ask you
this
have you thought about just getting
vaccinated and not telling her and not
talking about it yes
yes that has been my conclusion this
past
day or two i actually talked to a friend
and he's like
listen this i know it sucks but maybe
that's just the thing to do
the only so i've i figured that that's
probably the best option for me
um but now i've thought of
what am i going to do when i get my
vaccination card
um because we're going to be going to
we're going to be going out of town soon
and there's i find my i think
i try to think of head and will there
will there be a situation where
we know we aren't going to be allowed to
do something unless we have we show our
vaccination card
and you know i'm going to be vaccinated
but
she's not and well listen i mean
basically you would just if you want to
keep it secret you would just have to be
like
if there's a she's not going to be
allowed to do that thing anyway
so then maybe you're just both not doing
that thing and you don't need to worry
about it just just go out you'll you'll
be vaccinated but you can go out and do
your unvaccinated life with her i mean
i i agree that it sucks but if the
priority is you think it could be a
really bad situation for your child and
so you wanna
i i i it's really hard for me to give
serious you know
to to seriously give advice because i
don't know the full situation but
my immediate mind goes to at least get
yourself vaccinated and just don't
mention it
so that you are less likely to get the
virus and spread it to her
i i that's kind of what i've come to
there's only just one question i have
left
and um it's i i
want to get vaccinated but i want to uh
not give it away that i'm vaccinated by
having any side effects
so i i don't know what you recommend oh
you just say you're feeling under the
weather i mean the
the side effects you would have would be
sort of like feeling a little bit
cold or flu-like so you just say i've
i'm a little i've got a cold you know
okay yeah you said you got vaccinated
did you get the
which one did you get i got moderna
oh sorry cut off i can't hear you i got
moderna
okay all right skit so sounds
complicated sounds like um we're having
a
connection issue so i'm gonna let you go
but that's that's a tough situation
that's a tough situation
all right guys i've taken all the calls
i can take today
we will take calls again very soon